[Musique]
françois imaginez un enfant au burundi
dans un village reculé du sud du pays
santelli d'électricité pas de téléphone
après une petite pause de radio de
marque philips et ça c'est réservé
surtout aux adultes
la seule chose qui peut l'inspirer c'est
la nature c'est ce qui vaut tout de lui
imaginer ses rêves et cet empressement
quels thèmes et rêve à cette époque
moi je rêvais d'être médecin peut
imaginer pourquoi médecin effectivement
par hasard dans mon voisinage
si je dis voisinage s'est pas déjà m
c'est peut-être un kilomètre après avoir
dépassé deux ou trois collines il y
avait quelqu'un qui avait son fils aîné
qui venait de sortir de finisseur la
médecine et on en parle partout et moi
je voulais devenir comme lui surtout
qu'au fond de moi il y avait cette
filiation
parce que mes deux grandes soeurs
n'avaient pas pu finir même l'école
primaire parce que malgré ma merde et
avait convaincu que avec l'exploitation
familiale ils n'ont pas de quoi il avait
abandonné l'école non je ne voulais pas
voir même sort que j'ai gardé son rêve
dira toute ma mon parcours scolaire et
la société l'environnement n'a pas tardé
de me donner raison
parce que quand je finissais le bac je
vous préparer au bac la médecine chez
nous c'était digne des facultés qu'on
appellerait faculté noble et tout le
monde voulait soit être médecin ou bien
magistrats ou bien banquiers s'étaient
les trois métiers
les plus convoités et j'ai travaillé
comme un fou pour gagner le bac
si tous avec un meilleur score parce que
je voulais une inscription médecine
malheureusement j'ai eu mon bac mais
avec un scot herman pas donc vous pouvez
imaginer la suite j'ai été orienté dans
ligne de facultés les plus détestés
dehors de mon pays quand on parle de
facultés au fait religieux à la
profession surtout à la fonction
publique
je sais pas ce qu ici on n'aime pas
beaucoup burkina comme profession chez
nous c'est lancé m
[Musique]
donc j'étais oriane dans un département
de biologie chimie qui visait de former
des enseignants spécialisés et là un
beau pour moi c'était un choc parce que
mon rêve que j'avais nourrit depuis mon
enfance venait de s'envoler comme ça et
si tout ma famille mes amis autour de
moi tout le monde m'a pointé du doigt en
disant non quand même jusqu'à ce que
quelqu'un qui m'avait tellement aidé
durant tout mon parcours scolaire comme
c'est beaucoup souvent ici chez nous m'a
appelé m'a dit gira je suis vraiment
déçu de temps j'ai vécu que tu étais
intelligent
mais est ce que tu penses que tu
deviendras quelqu'un si tu fais cette
école cette information je les regarde
et je dis bon moi je pense que je
deviendrais quelques c'est là maintenant
que j'ai avec ce choc émotionnel
j'ai dit je me suis dit au fond de moi
même il y avait possibilité de devenir
soi puyo logist ou chimiste après la
formation
je me suis dit vas le vph et la chimie
pourquoi la chimie je viens dini je me
suis dit au moins après ma formation je
vais faire une usine de fabrication de
savon et pourquoi le savons je viens
donner les gens exploitent de l'ue de
parle et c'est l'une des principales
matières premier pour faire des savons
et à plein de dizin artisanale en plus à
gauche et déjà vous pouvez voir le
changement d'image dit rêve que j'avais
je viens de perdre le rêve de médecins
mais je me vois déjà je me projette
comme un grand pdg d'une grande
entreprise de savonner je vous disais
qu'avec ma formation quand même je fais
quelque chose de plus grand que tout ces
gens qui n'ont pas quand même pu aller à
l'école mais qui arrive à faire quelque
chose c'est ça que j'ai gardées dira
toute ma formation et j'ai commencé à
travailler
et maintenant ce soit je suis là
effectivement pour partager avec vous
comment j'ai pu sortie de ce cadeau fait
penser c'est dommage qu'on en a même
fait un cadre bon je vais je vais
laisser
je vais partager quelques créé savez
dans une maison à plusieurs criard écrit
qu ouvrir la porte principale ou
secondaire vous donner quelques clés qui
m'ont aidé carrément d'ouvrir certains
potes pour moi sorti la première chose
faut vraiment avoir une vision claire l
ai déjà dit ma vision de faire une usine
de fabrication de savon ça a été quelque
chose que j'ai gardées dira toute ma
formation et quand j'ai commencé à
travailler je voulais réaliser sur mes
jeux vite réalisé avec effecteur comme
on l'avait prédit
mais le salaire des enseignants qui me
sera vraiment difficile de réaliser mon
rêve
alors il fallait réfléchi et se donner
des moyens pour concrétiser son rêve
c'est là où je vais donner des deuxièmes
crie ça ne suffit pas d'avoir une vision
génial ou grands mais il faut agir pour
concrétiser cela et moi je m'étais donné
deux objectifs
je m'étais dit que mon salaire et il
faut que j'aie investissent dans des
petits micros projets dans l'espoir que
six jeux réels de grands bénéfices
je puisse faire quelque chose de plus
grand la deuxième objectif je m'étais
dit si je travaille je gagne une
possibilité de faire une formation pour
avoir un diplôme un peu plus élevée
master ou doctorat petit que ça vous
voulez d'autres opportunités pour
pouvoir concrétiser m'aurait conduit à
tout matériel d'enseignement pendant un
taux de 5 6 ans je me suis bâtie sur ces
deux fronts et je donne la troisième
cris si tu commences tu as des objectifs
je vais mettre en action tout mettre en
action
il ya quelque chose qu'il faut avoir à
côté de toi il faut s'armer de
persévérance
parce que les choses le chemin souvent
peut être long aussi long que tu ne l'as
pas imagine avec plein d'obstacles que
tu n'as pas passer quand j'ai commencé à
me lancer dans des projets
d'investissement j'avais un ami qui m'a
dit je connais un domaine si tu mets ton
argent des bénéfices at home comme deux
gouttes de la poule et là j'ai plus
toutes mes trois mois de salaires dès
les trois premiers mois de salaire j'ai
mis dedans c'était à la vente des
chaussures d'occasion
non c'est qu'on apprécie les flancs se
revoir mais non seulement j'ai failli de
bénéfices mais j'ai prédit le capitaine
après je me suis dit je ne m'arrête pas
là je me suis lancée de l'agriculture
deux saisons successives
je n'ai donné quoi c'est tout petit côté
formation depuis 2005 jusqu'en 2011
chaque année j'avais des dossiers que
j'ai envoyé un peu partout pour chercher
une formation plusieurs fois me dossiers
ont été rejetés au moins deux ou trois
quatre fois
surtout si je cherchais à pousser pour
des bourses du gouvernement ou si tous
les bouches de coopération qui sont
gérés par notre gouvernement parce qu'il
y avait un ministre avait pas un autre
rapport qui avait dit que normalement
les enseignants du secondaire ont pas
besoin de faire des formations à
l'étranger donc conquois ce qu'on avait
dit mais je m'étais dit au fond de moi
que je veux continuer à chercher on
enregistre cette année je reviens en un
projet parce que le mot disais je veux
chercher jusqu'à ce qu'on me dise que
j'ai dépassé la des titis à je vais
m'arrêter là 4e que je vais donner
il ne faut pas avoir peur de partager
et tes ambitions tes rêves souvent nous
sommes emprisonnés par un peu que les
gens vont se moquer de moi ou bien des
gens vont me voler ou bien si j'en avais
partagez pas mes ambitions
ce soit je ne sais pas ici en tout cas
je ne sais pas où beaucoup si je suis
venu vous connaissez via un ami qui me
connaissent et qu'ils connaissaient mes
ambitions qui est venu faire un doctorat
ici au burkina l'économie et qui a pu
conserver nikko d'ingénierie ci qui m'a
dit mon ami ya une école intéressante
ici le galsi qui ne peut pas trouver une
formation qui peut te dis c'est comme ça
que je suis et vous avez quand même dans
la suite que le fait de partager tes
ambitions thérèse ça peut parce que tu
ne sais pas parmi tout son monde s'était
beaucoup qui ne te crois pas qu'il
puisse y avoir quelqu'un qui va dit ah
si tu passes par cette porte s'apprête à
mener quelque part la donne est clair
que je vais donner qui est aussi
important il ne vous parlera peu de
saisies de plants des risques pour
saisir les opportunités que tu passes
qui sape est amené à réaliser terrienne
et bien des grands risques et j'ai pris
effectivement c'est de venir étudier au
bouquet
depuis deux ans mon bateau je cherchais
la formation et voilà en demi en 2011 je
vous tire la démission pour des yeux je
repars l'ambassade de france qui avait
rejeté le dossier années passées qui me
dit on a pas de financement pour ça je
reviens je dépose en même temps quoi et
moody's cette fois ci c'est bon tu peux
aller on peut subventionner de la
formation au bouquet est là la porte
s'ouvre
mais quand même il ya des difficultés à
côté ma femme qui travaille dans une
micro finance à microfis venait de faire
donc il faut pas moi j'arrête de
travailler et n'a pas de boulot
d'ailleurs à cette époque qu'elle était
enceinte de notre troisième enfant
et là si vous êtes deux maintenant il
faut négocier
je les appelais et les imac elle aussi
connaissait mais ambitieux mes rêves je
les dis est un peu commun et il m'a dit
si ces trois petits pouces 8 est raide
et ne recule pas de nous parce que dieu
va s'occuper d'eux il a vraiment joué ça
lui sert son courage et sa foi parce que
c'est ça qui m'a aidé du coup j'ai fermé
les yeux sans me demander combien de
voix on va me donner comme vous ça fait
des calculs et je débarque au bukina
arrivé au burkina les premiers cool
qu'on fait c'est sur la création
d'entreprise comme on écrit mme ghizlane
roy s'est dit ah je suis venu là où je
devais être
après le coup le pauvre ne donne un
exercice de simulation et là j'avais
appris qu'à l'école on faisait défaut
des compétitions de plan d'affaires
et quand nous enseigner c'est là que
maintenant mourir mon idée de savonner
lit de savons pas ce code a au départ
c'était fait des savons des savons de
savon de ménage de savon scène j'ai
aussi dit à quel est le problème
de l'empresa message quelle est la
différence avec les autres ça venait
c'est là que mille idées mais dit il
faut que je fasse à savoir des
moustiques pour pouvoir protéger les
gens contre par l'édition et j'ai
partagé cette idée dans l'exercie de
classe et la effective et avait un élève
un camarade de classe intéressant qui
est venu me voir après pour me dit mon
ami est ce que tu sais rien tu essaies
de participer avec moi dans une
compétition internationale
j'ai dit ok sans problème avait il dit
mais est ce que tu peux accepter qu'on
aussi ton idée de savoir tirer aussi
j'ai dit mords moi c'est je voulais
faire ça en interne mais tu veux compter
ça l'était nationale pourquoi pas au
niveau et c'est comme ça que d'un
chercheur fossiles et on a choisi le mot
face au sol qui est de venir face au sol
par tourner en bas ça ça vaut mieux
qu'il y est mais je vous assure je n'ai
pas ça ici ne me demande pas ces
parcours santé et on ne réalise pas que
au bout de quelques mois on allait se
retrouver aux états unis dans l'une des
grandes universités l'université de
berkeley en californie pour présenter
son projet et là on trouve des projets
venant plus de pas tout le monde et des
gens qui s'expriment très bien et une
petite anecdote accord on est arrivé il
y avait une histoire et on devrait
appeler tous les entrepreneurs venant
peu partout et nous on n'a pas participé
à ce lâcher toute l'équipe qui est venue
de l'afrique
et ouf on était enfermé dans la centre
et de répéter parce qu'on nous avait dit
il faut parler l'anglais que les
amériques et bon courage et là on était
dans des invités sauf sauf on ne savait
pas comment faire les deux morceaux et
le jeu de la finale alif
quand je regarde cette région dit mais
qu'est ce que je fais
avec une bulle de savon fait dans le
labo ici au burkina avec des projets qui
vient avec des projets bien amélioré
avec truqués de l'esj à marcher quoi dit
mr jeu dissidia paris qui je suis ici
c'est pour aller jusqu'au bout on appris
dans nos projets notre l'anecdote au
niveau de la réception pour la remise
des prix on avait mis sur la première
table et j'ai regardé l'une de mes
coaches je dis ça ne te dit pas quelque
chose qu'on nous amuser d'informer table
et mal gardé leur calme et toi ce que
vous avez déjà fait des ah c'est beau le
fait que vous est déjà arrivé ici c'est
déjà bon mais ne pense pas que vous et
les premiers c'était ok simplement que
c'est ainsi et en proclame le premier
prix est décerné à face au sort
[Applaudissements]
on revient au burkina comme des super
héros on en parle un peu partout on
chante dans les médias les jeunes à
risque qui sait afrique et aux etats
unis
bref je voulais 10 ce soir quand je fais
je regarde tout ce pack où je regarde
derrière tout le chemin parcouru ce
n'est pas encore fini je suis toujours
dans sa je me rappelle cette écurie
burkinabè qui ya émigré roma qui dit
petit p tit gars grand rêve
elle connaît on a gagné le berck les
ailes aux prix les anophèles son roman
et sojitz au petit gars qui a commencé à
arriver au fond fort loin actuellement
quand je regarde comment se porte le
projet face au soft combien de gens sont
derrière ce projet combien de personnes
différentes
l'institution qui soutient ce projet je
vous dis qu'il faut croire et aller
jusqu'au bout du terrain tu es tu as
quelque chose qui qui bouillons au fond
de toi tu est bloqué parce qu'on te dis
que ça ne va jamais marcher parce que la
société dit que ça c'est pas fait pour
vous
je ne fais que t'encourager si tu sais
que tu veux et tu sais où tu vial qui
tout va pour réaliser cela
total qui finit à trouver un chemin
comme disait sors je n'attends inter il
disait si le navire de la chance
n'arrive pas jusqu'à votre équipe il
faut analyser
je vous laisse
[Applaudissements]